hi everyone my name is john quackenbush
and i'm really happy to have the
opportunity to tell you about some of
the work that i
and my group are doing to look at the
problem of health disparities in
particular
the problem that we face in
understanding differences in disease
between males and females and i want to
tell you a little bit about how we're
using networks to understand
those differences in risk and to really
understand cancer risk in cancer
therapies so the starting point for a
lot of this is really the availability
of the human genome sequence and as most
of you know the genome was sequenced and
published
as a draft 20 years ago but that genome
while it gave us a catalog of all 25 000
genes really didn't solve the problem of
letting us understand how the genetic
program
encapsulated in those genes or encoded
in those genes plays itself out in all
the different cell types that exist in
our bodies
more importantly it didn't really
provide a complete understanding of how
that genetic
program plays itself out differently in
health and disease
so that's the challenge that i and my
colleagues have been wrestling with for
some time dealing with this kind of
biological complexity
and our answer to this problem of
understanding how the genome and the
genes it encodes really allow us to
understand the broad
scope of phenotypes that we see
is that networks of interacting elements
in the cell
actually mediate the translation between
the genetic code and the phenotypes that
we observe so my colleagues and i have
been building a whole host of different
tools for inferring and understanding
gene regulatory networks
and we tend to name them after animals
and because of that the collection of
tools
which we've assembled over the last few
years are included in a package that we
call net zoo or the network zoo and this
is an integrated set of tools in r
python matlab and c with most tools
implemented in all languages that allow
us to look at gene regulatory networks
to model them
and to start to compare them between
different phenotypic groups to really
get a better understanding of these
intricate biological processes that are
taking place
so i'm going to look at those tools in
the context of asking a variety of
questions and the first is can we simply
model the gene regulatory process
one of the fundamental things that
allowed me to really start thinking
about this problem um in a very nuanced
way was a paper that one of my students
emira jabari showed me now almost 20
years ago and this was a paper by
wilbert
who were two computer scientists working
at microsoft on the problem of
optimization
and in looking at this problem what they
recognized was that many people were
using sort of black box algorithms to
try to solve these
optimization problems
but
that there was no way to really use
these to get general purpose solutions
that work in all possible situations and
the last highlighted sentence here was
one that was really key for me
these same results also indicate the
importance of incorporating
problem-specific knowledge into the
behavior of the algorithm
what that says is if you want to solve a
very difficult nearly intractable
computational problem the best way to
start is by incorporating what you know
about the system and making an educated
guess as to how the solution should work
and that's really been the fundamental
tool uh the fundamental idea that
underlies our development of a lot of
these different methods so the very
first method and very first animal in
our zoo that we developed was a method
that we call panda and this was work
that i do with kimberly glass who's one
of my close colleagues and collaborators
curtis huttenhauer gcuan and it was
really based on our understanding of how
regulation occurs in the cell that if
we're going to make an rna right and
that's really the output of this gene
regulatory process if we're going to
make an rna the
the synthesis of that rna is really
enabled by the binding of proteins
called transcription factors to regions
around that gene that either activate or
potentially repress the regulatory
process
and so the starting point for our
modeling is really recognizing that
transcription factors are sending
messages
that are turned into rna through this
transcriptional regulatory process
but regulation is very complex so how do
we sort out all the different potential
factors that are acting well one of the
things we recognize is that if two genes
are regulated by the same transcription
factor they're likely to be co-expressed
in the same way we write we recognize
that transcription factors often form
complexes
and if they do
protein-protein interaction data that
suggests transcription factors can bind
together
can provide some evidence for
co-regulation
so
the way we really implement this method
is to recognize that we have multiple
sources of data and information that
what we can do if we want to infer a
regulatory network that models the way
in which transcription factors activate
or repress genes
is to start with a guess as to what that
network looks like so to scan the genome
to look for transcription factor motifs
and to postulate what that network might
look like
but then as i mentioned earlier we do
have other sources of data and
information like protein-protein
interaction data between transcription
factors co-regulation data between genes
and a particular phenotype and so what
we can do is estimate functions that
show either how
available the genes are or how active or
responsible the transcription factors
are and carry out this regulatory
process and then we look for consistency
among these data sets we update our
network model and then we iterate the
process until we converge on a final
network
once we have that what we do
is we look at the data we have available
and much of that data is data that comes
from experiments like gene expression
experiments we can always do things like
look for differentially expressed genes
but what we try to do is for each
phenotype infer a network and then
combine the data and information we have
to look at the structure and topology of
the network how that structure and
topology changes between phenotypes and
then integrating those changes with
information about the genes including
expression and other data to really
arrive at an understanding of what's
driving the individual phenotypes we're
trying to study
in addition what we've started to
recognize over time is that we can take
the individual samples and for each
sample in the population we can infer
and network for that individual and we
can start to look at differences between
individual networks and think of those
networks and the structures as really
being complex biomarkers that allow us
to understand how differences in
regulatory processes are predictive of
biological state or things like response
to therapy
so this has been the fundamental
paradigm that we've used to get to that
state though of looking at individual
sample networks what we have to think
about doing
is really looking at how we move from an
aggregate network for each phenotypic
group that we study
to really understanding
how we tease out individual networks and
the way we do that is actually to use a
simple linear interpolation method that
allows us to infer from that one network
networks for each individual in the
population we want to study so the idea
is very simple that what we can do
is we can look at a single sample
network
by starting off inferring the network
for the entire population but then
leaving out an individual sample and
asking what is the effect of leaving out
that network in inferring or leaving out
that sample and inferring the network
and it won't surprise you that by
leaving out a sample we can actually
subtly change some of the connections in
the network especially if i look at the
differences between them i can see the
the effect of leaving out that
particular sample and if you think about
it just a little bit it's pretty easy to
convince yourself that if you scale
those differences by the number of
samples in the network and add it back
to the network without the the sample
that's been left out
you can actually estimate that
individual sample network so it's very
easy to write this out it's very easy to
solve this problem edge by edge in the
network and arrive at an underlying
network model so this is something we've
also published this is called lioness
and
the nys the lioness method has been used
in a wide variety of different problems
some of those we've looked at are
looking at tissue-specific regulation in
38 different tissues using data from
gtex and then in 29 of those tissues
where we had male and female samples
addressing this understudied problem of
what the differences are between the
sexes in terms of the processes that
drive phenotype
so
with these two questions answered the
third question we wanted to sort of
address is do networks actually matter
do they give us something beyond what we
can look at or what we can understand by
simply exploring differential expression
so earlier this year
debbie weghill i and some others took a
look at this in a very focused way
because we understand
the importance of networks but many
people have asked us to really provide
some level of support and we started by
looking at the very simple question of
what we see in networks and part of what
we see
is co-expression we see groups of genes
activated together that
carry out particular processes
so we asked can you just look at a
simple toy model in this case we have
four genes and nine individuals where
the patterns of gene expression change
and we also looked at patterns that
change where
some genes are correlated and some are
not and what we were able to show in
this little toy model was that you can
see differences not only in expression
but actually in patterns of
co-expression that may provide some
insight into what is occurring in the
system beyond looking at individual
genes because if a group of genes are
being activated or repressed together
you can start to imagine that the
processes that they're involved with are
somehow involved in this phenotype
beyond what we'd see by looking at the
individual genes themselves
so the real question was could we apply
this idea to looking more broadly not
only at coexpression but at gene
regulatory networks
so what debbie decided to do was to look
at tcga data from pancreatic cancer and
to use these network methods to compare
two different subtypes in pancreatic
cancer
looking not only at gene expression and
coexpression
but then also looking at whether or not
particular genes in our gene regulatory
network models using panda and linus are
targeted in different ways and what's
really exciting about this analysis is
that what debbie was able to show
what debbie was able to show
was that when we look at these
individual networks there are things
that are specific shown here in the
middle in blue to looking at gene
expression but not necessarily that
informative there are things that we can
see using coexpression that are also
seen in looking at the regulatory
network models but that the regulatory
network models actually identify
different processes that are targeted
specifically in pancreas and different
subtypes of pancreatic cancer that
includes things like immune related
processes epigenetic processes and cell
cycle processes that we couldn't see
looking at this data from any other
vantage point so these regulatory
networks beyond co-expression networks
beyond co-expression by itself beyond
expression by itself
really give us
unique insight into processes which are
important for understanding disease
so the question is how do we apply that
and how do we look at this question that
i opened with
the question of understanding how males
and females differ in cancer risk in
cancer response so
we've looked at this problem looking at
colon cancer and this is a really nice
example because one of the things that
we understand
is that male and female cancers are in
fact different in their risks and
outcome so in 2016 there's a nice review
published in nature of used cancer that
looks at males that looked at males and
females
looking at both cancer incidents and
cancer mortality showing dramatic
differences in a number of different
cancers
and what this article really points out
is that men and women have a different
natural history
in developing diseases like cancer have
different response to therapy
and in fact often manifest disease in
ways that are different and unique to
those individuals so what we decided to
do was to look at colon cancer
colorectal cancer and to use data from
tcga to begin to explore these
differences
to look at the regulatory processes that
are different and then to ask can we
actually replicate these findings in
other studies
so this is the basic outline of the
study
that we proposed that we undertook we
took data from either tcga
or geo
we did batch correction we did
normalization and then we looked since
we're looking at males and females at
just how many individual samples we
could accurately annotate as being male
or female samples
we ended up with 445 in our discovery
set and almost 1200
in our validation set both almost evenly
divided between males and females
i mentioned that one of the things we
did was that we looked at
the sex
or we looked to try to check the sex of
the individuals and this is something
that we've discovered over time in
looking at sex differences is actually
very important
because one of the fundamental
assumptions that we make is that females
are not doing not going to express y
chromosome genes and that males should
most of these studies don't look at
gender they look at sex so the
biological sex
of the patients we're looking at should
really discriminate between those who
have x chromosomes or y chromosomes and
those who don't and what's shown here
the samples that are annotated as female
in red
and you can see the samples that are
annotated in male and blue and there are
a few males who are scattered among that
small clump of females on the left
and a few females who are scattered
through the group of males on the right
that suggest that these
individuals may have been somehow
misassigned sex or that their data may
somehow have been scrambled there are
some studies where we see low incidence
of this there are other studies where we
see as many as 20 of the samples that
seem to be misidentified by sex
causing us to question many of the other
annotations in those data sets
nevertheless this is an important part
of our quality control particularly if
we're looking at the importance of sex
in moderating health and disease
so
one of the things we started with was
this basic assumption that males and
females are going to be expressing genes
differently
and
all of this data was performed using
surgical samples
at the time of surgery before
chemotherapy
and
or any adjuvant treatment and what we
did was we looked at differential
expression as our first baseline measure
probably not surprising to most of you
is that when we found differential
expression
essentially all that differential
expression we found that was significant
to any measure whatsoever
were on genes that were located on the x
and y chromosomes
and probably not surprisingly none of
these genes actually explain anything
about the observed clinical differences
we see
in males and females who have colon
cancer
so we asked ourselves how can we go
beyond this how can we look at networks
to understand this so we followed a very
simple protocol we downloaded the data
we inferred gene regulatory networks for
males and females and then we looked at
differential targeting essentially we
looked at the number of edges that are
regulating each gene in these regulatory
models and added up their weights
then we did a simple statistical test
for the
collection of networks for males
comparing to the collection of networks
for females and asked are there
differences
in the relative edge weights or the
differential targeting right the the sum
of the edge weights and the differential
targeting of particular genes
in males and females we did this
correcting for stage age race and other
covariates
and then once we found those
differentially regulated genes we asked
what do those genes do and what does it
tell us about disease
so
not surprisingly we found
one
gene that seemed to be differentially
targeted on the x chromosome but many
other genes on the autosome there were
either upregulated males or sorry
increased in their targeting in males or
up targeted in females
and when we looked at those what we saw
unlike looking at the differential
expression data was that there are many
genes involved in processes that we
could link back
to specific differences in disease
development progression and most
important in response to therapy because
one of the things we know is that males
and females respond differently to
chemotherapy
in looking at this differential
targeting analysis what we found was the
genes in the drug metabolism pathway
were far more strongly targeted in
females than males
and what this suggested to us is that
males and females are likely to respond
differently to chemotherapy something we
know happens clinically now this was a
really rewarding finding for us because
these samples were taken before any
chemotherapy
was given to these patients right these
are surgical samples at the time of
surgery before treatment with
chemotherapy
and so
even though we know the clinical
endpoint or the clinical outcome is that
males and females respond differently to
chemotherapy
this model this regulatory interaction
or regulatory network modeling
tells us that that's something that we
should suspect and more than that
actually tells us what genes are likely
to be involved in the differential
response that we see
so we looked beyond our discovery cohort
to our validation cohort and what we
found was that in that validation cohort
males and females responded differently
to chemotherapy
just as we would have predicted and that
the genes that are activated in males
and females that are differentially
targeted in men and women
are actually
overlapping to a very large extent
and so what we were able to do is really
validate the findings that suggest
that
regulation of genes in men and women is
a big part of what distinguishes
outcomes in response to therapy
so then the question is if we look at
men and women and we look at the
regulatory networks what does this tell
us about the ultimate response of these
individuals to treatment and what was
particularly exciting in looking at
these data
is that when we took a step back
and asked among those individuals who
had very high targeting
and very low targeting
of the drug metabolism pathway
are there differences in outcomes
and what we found that was most
interesting was that among the males
there was very little difference in
targeting and in fact very little
difference in outcome
well if we looked at the females
those that had more female
characteristic
targeting
profiles
behaved or had much better outcome than
those who had more
male-like targeting profiles
that in fact the the targeting uh the
low-targeting group of females as we
might have predicted
respond
and have outcome profiles that are much
more like those of their male
counterparts in the same studies
so what this really suggests
is that there are regulatory processes
that are active in females that if they
are increased in their activity
actually have long-term survival
benefits in terms of response to
chemotherapy and outcome
it also suggests that by starting to
dive in and understand what those
regulatory differences are
we might begin begin to think
about ways in which we can treat male
and female cancers differently
or we might be able to think about ways
in which we can treat subgroups of
individuals differently
to change their response profiles by
moderating or modifying the way in which
these regulatory processes are active in
their individual disease states
so
one of the other questions we can start
to ask since males and females respond
differently
is whether or not males and females
actually have different genetic risks
and i don't have time to talk about this
in great detail today but one of the
other questions we explored was looking
not at transcription factors but at eqtl
data looking at the interaction between
snips and genes and what we found was
that in looking at eqtl networks
cancer risk snips
actually
are associated with the regulation of
oncogenes and tumor suppressor genes so
that snips found through gewa studies
are actually those that regulate
are associated with differential
regulation of oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes as well as other genes
that are involved in cancer-related
processes
so we started to ask ourselves well can
we take that in data and information and
combine it with the kind of ideas that i
talked about with lioness inferring
individual sample networks and comparing
them between men and women
and recently we developed a new method
called egret that looks at the
association between
snips that occur in the genome that are
in eqtls with genes that we want to
understand genes for which we want to
understand the regulatory processes
to infer
individual specific
genotype specific
regulatory models
and so this paper described in this
analysis is available on bioarchive i
don't have time to take you through it
it's about i hope to be accepted in a
journal and should be published soon we
sent in second revisions but i'm always
hesitant to mention journals until we
actually get
the certified acceptance but the paper's
been up on bioarchive there's code to
execute this in the network zoo
and i invite you to take a look at it
because it's really exciting what it
suggests is these regulatory snips
combined with differences in regulatory
processes between males and females may
really help us to understand how disease
risk itself
is
moderated
in the two different sexes
individually
so the last question i want to ask is
what does this all tell us about drugs
and drug response
and again i don't have time to go into
great detail here but i want to bring to
your attention another resource that i
and my colleagues have developed
and this is largely work done by maro
and ben gabila
to build the database and data resource
that we call grand grand is a gene
regulatory network database
the url is down at the bottom
and what marowan did in the assembling
grant was first address the question
that we were wrestling with or a problem
that we were wrestling with and that was
the problem of not having a database and
we in which we could store these
regulatory models that we were building
and so marijuana set out to to
amalgamate these
and consolidate them in a single
searchable reference resource
in doing that he ended up running a lot
of other network inference models on a
problem that he was interested in namely
response to drugs in response to
therapeutics and he ended up building a
resource that in some ways is like the
connectivity map but instead of looking
at differences in gene expression
and changes in gene expression to
predict potential drug
candidates what maryland did is really
looked at the kind of things that i am a
group have been looking at for a long
time these differences in network
structures
so built into grand
is actually a tool that we call clue reg
and what clue reg does is it looks at
networks that were derived try cell
lines that were treated with drugs both
before and after treatment to see
changes in the regulatory
regulatory processes
then what one can do
is look at your own individual network
models that you've inferred using tools
like panda and lioness and you can take
those network models and simply ask
what drugs might actually do the sorts
of things i was talking about earlier
what drugs might actually take a
regulatory network model and change them
in ways that will provide insight into
how to better treat disease to get the
the responses that we're looking for and
anticipate
so one of the examples i just want to
show here in brief is a comparison
between
differential colon cancer networks
looking at the high targeting and low
targeting nodes the same kind of
differences we've seen between men and
women
and in looking at these differences
one of the things that klureg found
was an experimental drug called mk5109
that's a candidate therapy for colon
cancer and in fact this is a drug that's
shown
activity and non-small cell lung
carcinoma another disease in which there
is
a strong difference between men and
women in overall disease development and
response to therapy
so what we're starting to see is a
really exciting picture that emerges
from looking at gene regulatory networks
what these networks allow us to do is to
really get at changes that we can't see
in other ways
changes in regulatory processes that
help explain disease
changes in regulatory processes that
help explain one of the most
underexplored questions in modern
biology why are men and women different
in the way they develop disease and
respond to therapy
and more importantly if we see these
differences how can we begin to identify
drugs that may be more efficacious in
treating one subgroup
or another whether they be males and
females or
good responders and poor responders
based on their regulatory processes the
processes that fundamentally control
gene expression so why do we bother with
net with networks well in numerous
applications we found that networks
provide insight to disease that is not
found using expression or call
expression
differential targeting captures not only
a phenotypes current expression but also
its potential to respond remember in
this colon cancer example we're looking
at surgical samples before chemotherapy
yet we would predict based on the
regulatory processes that males and
females were likely to respond
differently something that we observe
clinically
and then last but not least that the
changes in network structure can help
identify both drivers of disease
as well as potential therapeutic targets
so i hope you enjoy this presentation i
just want to say this has been the work
of a really
wonderful group of people i've worked
with over the years including people who
work with me here at the harvard chan
school of public health
former alumni or i guess current alumni
of our group who've gone on to other
institutions
and really a talented group of faculty
staff students postdocs who have
supported this endeavor over time
so thank you for joining me in today's
meeting um and if you have any questions
you don't get a chance to ask today or
for some reason things don't work out
and we don't get a chance to connect my
email address is at the top and i look
forward to hearing from all of you
thanks and enjoy the rest of the
conference